If you entrust me with the presidency you do not pay any tax at all because we don't need a tax code.
Let me take this moment to say something we don't say nearly enough
the days of cozying up to the law is
over.
I will not let that happen you have my
word.
Give people school choice with results
available immediately.
I hear their voices if you listen you
can hear them too, no nearly a century
ago Franklin Roosevelt pledged a new deal
too much power
and my fellow americans that is
unforgivable
those are words for our time under
president biden american soldiers
military stay in their homes with
dignity
i accept this nomination thank you and
may god bless you
and may god protect our life liberty and
the pursuit of happiness